Hey YouTubers i'ts Charlie! This is my game
of thrones episode nine video, so much internal
screaming this week. Careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet and new
round of the giveaway starts now all you have
to do to enter is be a Subscriber to leave
a comment on this video. So here we go let's
begin the top seven with Shireen Baratheon
story the dance of the dragons she's been
so much fun this season and she's one of the
characters is one of the few characters that
reads a lot apparently she also reads George
RR Martin side stories that's the dance the
dragons is he completely exploited in the
episode it's all about the Targaryen Civil
War that tale provides the emotional core
of the episode you have like the dance that's
going on in Daznak's. Like the literal dance
people dance around each other with swords
then you have the internal dance that Stannis
was talking about a man fighting his true
nature he gives you a rare clip so what's
going on inside his head do I sacrifice my
daughter and become the man I was supposed
to be he looks like a ghost in this hardest
things that been on them you know as Winters
said in it's also because is been weighing
the decision to sacrifice Shireen if you haven't
read the short story it's a lot of fun there
aren't any spoilers in it for the main novels
or the TV show or anything like that is it's
completely separate is also the funny story
about balance want trying to hide behind this
really pretty shield the full Dragon it totally
not working obviously nice hat tip to what
happened with Drogon at the end of the episode
you can also look at it is an allegory to
what's going on between the Boltons and Stannis
his army right now the Boltons trying to hide
behind the shield of winter may be what happened
with Drogon at the end of the episode says
something about what's going to happen with
this Stannis Ramsey plot this is the theory
though it's been all day parsing imagery in
game of thrones but you know what a character
like Shireen spends a long time explaining
something it's a big deal so pay careful attention
to what she said in this episode and what
it might mean for the other characters in
the show on December 6 Stannis sends Davos
goes back to the wall to get more supplies
it reminded me of the story of house or Davos
became the onion night first of his name at
the notes, like Bronn becoming the first night
of the Blackwater to somewhat unlikely people
helping out really rich people that raise
them up to knighthood Davos's stories just
a little bit grander than Bronn story with
during Robert's rebellion Stannis got stuck
defending storms then the opposing force just
chose to start him out so slowly over time
Stannis just had everyone eat all the horses
all the animals started boiling their shoes
this sort of boiling leather and eating that
slowly starving to death Davos came in and
brought them a bunch of onions like he's small
than food for them so Stannis would not be
alive were it not for Davos so that's why
he made him the onion night and true to his
word Stannis very fair man cut off all of
his finger joints on one hand Stannis is very
fair but very hard that's why he told him
to kill all the guards that let Ramsey come
in and burn their supplies he does is going
to give anybody a pass nobody gets a free
ride with Stannis on Semper Fi though John
Snow brings the survivors through to the other
side of the wall as he said he views the mission
is a failure because they they barely got
anybody but they did manage to get out with
some of the Wildlings sleep do have more people
now there was a real question though is to
whether or not Alliser Thorne was can let
them through the gate I was surprised how
quickly he did it to get a good hard John
Snow is going to get us all killed it's interesting
that you see more hate coming off the faces
of the regular nights watch brothers Alliser
Thorne doesn't seem like he harbors that much
of a grudge right now that's okay though it
seems like all he hates John Snow enough for
the two of them you have to remember that
almost like 50 of them died trying to keep
the Wildlings from coming through that gate
that they just walk through that's why it
was really sad when Wun Wun came through and
everyone flipped Wun Wun is the name of the
giant that survived remember the other one
was killed in the tunnel by Grenn long-live
Grenn the giant slayer's everything they were
trying to prevent from happening last season
just happened that's why they hate John Snow
so much onto number for evereybody versus
Hizdahr you have his dart throwing shade it
Daario throw Shade right back at them then
you have tearing mincing words of them and
I like Tyrion's comment that Tywin would've
totally loved Hizdahr killing is necessary
what progress has been made without killing
is messes Daario's idea about pulling a red
wedding on the noble houses Marine seemed
a couple weeks ago it doesn't seem like such
a bad idea now the problem is is if you kill
a lot of people no matter why you do it it's
really hard to call yourself a good person
that's the internal battle that's going on
in Daenerys right now you just like Stannis
has his own internal battle trying to decide
whether not to sacrifice his daughter what
does Daenerys have to do to become the person
she was meant to be probably kill a few people
that you meet it was just fun watching everyone
throw Shane Hizdahr's ovary seemed pretty
innocuous but I felt like they were telegraphing
it in these moments that they wanted you to
view him as the bad person Hizdahr is all
that the old way to Daenerys is about the new so
out with the old in with the new onto
number three Ser Jorah enters the fighting.
It's pretty clear that Daenerys wants to help
him but can't do anything and obviously in
reference to the dance in the dragons tidal
surge aura dances with Alonzo the fighters
just barely makes it out but he is a bad ass
fighter so he does when the reason I think
that everyone was booing him is because he
was a westeros he night and they were cheering
for the local fighters a lot of the people
hate Daenerys because they still view her
as an invading force she's from another culture
and she isn't respecting their soap so I think
that's why they hated surge or so much because
he represented that the announcer made it
very clear to annouce to everyone that Jorah was
a westerosi knight so no matter what he did
people probably weren't going to like him moving onto
number to the Doran Martell lets Jamie go
back to Kings Landing with Myrcella but he
has to take Trystane with them this is a small
change in the box so whenever Tyrion arranged
for Myrcella to go to Dorn way way back in
season two before Blackwater part of the deal
was he gave the Martell's a seat on the small
council that's from the books they didn't
really address that on the show until now
oberyn was originally supposed to take the
seat he died so now there's an Seat that belongs
to the Martellls in the books it ends up being
Obara to go to Kings Landing and sit on the
small counsel so still Martell but a different
one there wasn't much of a climax this week
in the in the door storyline aside from the
slap fight that was going on everybody gets
slapped sand snakes and Bronn it was nice
of all or is sent to tell Jamie you know I
know exactly what's going on with you and
Cersei and is no big deal if you'd been born
a Targaryen or a long time ago when the been
anything and finally for my number one years
because there was so much internal screaming
this weekend and split it between Shireen
Baratheon being put to the torch and Daenerys
writing Drogon let's start with her sweetheart
sorry that this is the saddest moment I think
all season Thursday I can't remember anything
else that may be this upset who's going to
read stories to serve Davos now and what's
can happen to Stannis now that it looks like
he's killed the only thing that he loves I'm
sure he cares about stories but it seemed
like Shireen was like the purest expression
of his love even crazy pants Alyce was like
this is a terrible idea she is a good barometer
for the audience in this moment you just you
see like the spectrum of emotions that crossed
her face from like okay you know we need to
do this all the way to all my God know this
is happening is the question for you guys
were you more upset about what happened to
Sansa with Ramsey episode six or about this
about Shireen being put to the torch moving
up to Daenerys and Drogon about this that
actually been spoiled last year little bed
and a lot of behind-the-scenes stuff so it
was good happen it's a big moan from the books
Drogon comes down at the Daznak spit roast
a bunch of people then takes off with Daenerys
is incredibly cathartic and she did you know
she does like her Jedi mind trick that's not
in the books so that the shows, making a logically
there she has a connection with Drogon but
the books never fully explained the nature
of that Dragon bonding get tied up in a little
bit of blood magic little bit of sorcery is
is very complicated hopefully the books will
planned at some point I felt like the CG of
him taking off like the skyline in the pyramid
in the background looked way better than the
CG of him landing when he flew in his he did
look quite as big as I imagined them but I'm
really glad that they did not wait for the
finale to do this and already mentioned either
but we also aria story with Mary Tran I'm
actually I'm a little happier that they did
say that for the finale because they were
not done that if it wasn't to be just some
mind blowing seemed she was going to have
they want there to be no question about how
evil Mehran Trent is anxious out when they
trotted Rian with the oysters he is going
to be like a perfect age let's do it he almost
made it sound like he was going to destroy
that serving girl they walked off with like
why would he need another tomorrow night if
he wasn't going to do something terrible to
the one he had this night and is pretty clear
that Jaquen knows exactly what's going on
all you know he wasn't hungry maybe tomorrow
and Jaquen like yeah I I know exactly what
you're doing maybe tomorrow it's all the same
to the many phase God probably interested
to see what Jaquen does if aria actually does
and killing Mehran Tran that's actually another
good question do you think that FRA ends up
killing Mehran Tran that Jaquen will make
her leave next week's episode is the finale
it's called mother's mercy that could mean
a a lot of things mercy as and Daenerys as
the mother of dragons show some mercy in the
books aria took the name mercy when she was
on a mission like this that we have like the
Sansa Ramsey Bolton storyline you know what
does mother's mercy say about that it is anything
that I'm really surprised about at this point
it's that they drug out this Cersei storyline
out I actually thought and baby gone to the
trial by now I'm wondering if they're going
to send Jamie and Myrcella and everyone back
to Kings Landing before that happens uses
the duration the finale is a little bit longer
so you have a little bit more room to do extra
stuff so now's the time to make predictions
for the finale so I alternately do like season
six predictions was we get through but it's
it's a little early because there still so
many things that they could change in the
books in the last episode is much as they
been moving really quickly through books form
five if you like season six will include some
stuff that they cut out from previous books
we can talk about that in a couple weeks and
don't forget tomorrow's the Q&A on us the
winner of the giveaway all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video just in case you guys
didn't see it I did a bonus video today all
about Asshai and dragons and how the history
those two are connected you can click here
to watch that and you can click here for last
week's episode thank you so much for watching,
everybody high five and I'll see you tomorrow!